là où ça bouge ça bouge oualalou
c'est début des vacances alors on vous a
préparé toute une liste d'idées de
sorties et de bons plans avec vos
enfants théâtre comptines emma il y en a
dans à peu près toute la région alors
vous allez pouvoir y emmener vos petits
anges
enfin vos petits démons plutôt ça dépend
des jours et ça commence tout de suite
ici au luxe par un atelier d'animation
et je vous préviens les gars vous avez
intérêt expliquez-nous un petit peu en
quoi consiste cet atelier alors c'est un
atelier d'initiation au cinéma
d'animation
alors on découvre quoi concrètement à
travers cet atelier alors ça permet aux
enfants de comprendre toutes les étapes
de fabrication d'un film de l'histoire
au tournage et après la mise en voix
alors concrètement là par exemple qu'est
ce que vous leur expliquer alors je leur
explique que avec tous les personnages
là ils peuvent effectivement faire les
séquences de films en prenant plusieurs
photos les unes à la suite des autres et
elle en faisant défiler une certaine
vitesse et c'est vraiment le principe de
la suisse ne vous dévoiler les coulisses
du film d'animation est là en espérant
que havrais quand ils vont dans les
salles dont ils ont une autre regard sur
ce qui c'est sur ce qu'ils voient
alors c'est destiné aux enfants de 7 à
12 ans et ça se passe ici au luxe ces
ateliers sont inspirés du travail de
cécile dalmau qui vous est illustratrice
à caen
quelle est la ligne directe très simple
de cette exposition alors la ligne
directrice de cette expo c'est que tout
ce qui est exposé là les dessins qui
sont exposées là sont des inédits quitte
à dire qu'ils n'ont jamais été utilisés
ni dans un album ni pour un travail de
communication visuelle
concrètement l'exposition est visible ou
et jusqu'à quand alors justement l'expo
est visible au cinéma lux à caen
jusqu'au 3 janvier sur les horaires
larges que sont ceux du cinéma et c'est
gratuit
nous traîneau et déjà sortis et les
lutins sont s'y affairer qu'ils
remarquent à peine les deux visiteuses
lola est très impressionné par
l'efficacité des luttes à elle n'aurait
jamais pensé à un toboggan pour les
cadeaux et si pour occuper vos enfants
pendant les vacances tout simplement
vous leur part liée d'art l'art c'est un
mot qui fait peur aux grands mais pas
forcément aux petits c'est ce qu'on va
vous faire découvrir tout de suite avec
une médiatrice culturelle
c'est un portrait peint par pablo
picasso allez ne fait pas c'est est là y
six mois aux voleurs voleurs entente il
alors crier voilà quand il pleut du
monstrueux quand tu n'as rien à faire et
d'allemand soit la bonne chose mais
regardent sur internet pour faire un
petit bricolage c'est avoir des jambes
je la trouve assez drôle c'est la belle
sont ceux que je préfère me contre vous
c'est parce que c'est drôle et que c'est
bon ça te plait fond je trouve ça
commence une boule de bien et pourquoi
c'est bien
pour rejoindre tableau de les faire
comme un fait ton tout simplement quand
on est parent pour parler d'art à ses
enfants
alors on utilise un vocabulaire de tous
les jours donc on se met vraiment à la
hauteur des enfants on se dit aussi
qu'on va prendre un bon moment ça va
être un moment de partage donc on
utilise du vocabulaire simple avec les
mots de tous les jours on peut utiliser
par exemple les livres ça c'est vraiment
très bien partir d'un livre qui a fini
par faire un petit bricolage que l'état
doit faire il ya des petits livres qui
sont vraiment bien c'est avec des
personnages qui connaissent déjà
on peut faire parler les oeuvres d'art
en disant comme si c'était une bulle de
bd ou imiter les statuts ou les
peintures en se prenant en photo puis ça
nous fait un petit souvenir par région
et une autre solution pour parler d'art
rendez vous tous les premiers mercredis
du mois à l'artothèque à caen c'est tout
nouveau et c'est une façon de découvrir
l'art en famille ça s'appelle goûter
l'art et n'oubliez pas les infos il faut
être là où ça bouge
regardez les ouvrages
merci père noël et pour finir l'agenda
avec d'abord du cinéma neige et les
arbres belgique sera projeté dans toute
la région
c'est quoi c'est pas un look
du cirque avec la compagnie gondwana
allègre demain à 15 heures
et du théâtre à lisieux pour les tout
petits le 23 décembre
bref on vous souhaite de superbes
vacances là où ça bouge revient le 5
janvier bonnes fêtes à tous
et toujours